Victoria Beckham gets criticized for
kissing her daughter on the lips I hope
my daughter wants to kiss me on the lips
10 15 20 30 years so now that's my
daughter I gave birth to her online
haters reaction to Victoria's kiss quote
ooh it looks like they are making out
totally wrong hope she gets so
passionate with David Beckham we just
realized he'll never make everybody
happy there's 50% of the world is gonna
be Maddie to deal one way or another way
but many celebrity moms have come under
attack Kristin Cavallari was shamed for
this snap criticism poured in sank her
two and three year old sons looked too
skinny she fired back saying yep i
starved my children reese witherspoon
got heat for giving her son tennessee
cinnamon rolls for breakfast Jersey
Shore's JWoww who's using 3:10
nutrition's helped drop baby weight told
us today about getting slammed just for
taking ten week old Grayson to the pool
how dare you put your kid in a
chlorinated pool he's only two months no
SPF just because what I don't have a
sign non chlorination saltwater pool and
like there's not like a picture of what
SPF I use in the background I don't want
to be rude but I picture what a troll it
people better just like please II
sitting in their underwear like behind
their computer screens just going off
because they have nothing better and
life to do if you go after my kids then
I'm gonna attack you cuz you have no
right ginger Zee was accused of
abandoning her three-month-old for
Dancing with the Stars Melissa Joan Hart
for letting her son still use a pacifier
when he was two Chrissy Teigen was
criticized for going on a date night
nine days after giving birth to her
daughter Luna and even for eating sugary
cereal while pregnant fruity pebbles
really we're gonna fight about it it
gets exhausting all when I get it right
and we're all doing our best like I
don't know a mother who say you know
I'm gonna suck at being a mom today so
the question is how two stars handle the
hate welt like Jennifer Aniston and her
powerful op-ed the message is no matter
who you are don't judge I love Jennifer
Aniston I love what she wrote women are
perfect whether they have kids whether
they don't have kids whether they have
husbands they don't and whether they
decide to eat a cheeseburger or not and
have a little blow and I think it's
partly because we're also criticizing
each other it's always you can't look
like Amy Schumer like you shouldn't be
like that a woman can be perfect just
being who she is